but we begin with the impact of the
latest extreme weather system to hit
California evacuation orders remain in
place for parts of the state after the
newest storm hammered the region
yesterday mudslides could bring danger
long after the rain has stopped the
death toll has risen to at least 20
since late December Chris Vancleave is
in Ojai California for us with the
latest
morning Ventura County got about 17
inches of rain in the last week you can
see the impact of the water on roads
here hillsides have come down and even
though the rain has stopped the danger
really hasn't across California from up
north in San Francisco all the way down
to San Diego there remains concerns
about flooding and especially mudslides
this is just all our backyard area we
had a barbecue over there Marjorie Cruz
and her husband woke up to the Roar of
cascading mud slamming into their
Berkeley California home of more than 20
years it was very terrifying and when it
started because it's trees and debris
mud piling up to their roof breaking
through their home and flowing into
their backyard wiping out their patio
and shed it's pretty summering you know
23 years we haven't seen anything I
haven't seen anything like that here
where it's actually taken out of home
more than 500 landslides like this one
have occurred Statewide since the new
year and more than 100 slides between
just Sunday and Monday alone
fire crews in Santa Cruz captured this
dramatic scene as a road collapsed the
asphalt buckling and crumbling down a
hillside the danger doesn't just stop
once the rain stops David Montgomery is
a professor of geomorphology at the
University of Washington for some of the
deeper larger landslides where it takes
longer time for that water to seep down
to the layers that are destabilized it
can take weeks and sometimes even months
for the danger to really be passed
in San Diego Rising Waters remained a
problem search and rescue teams worked
to reach at least seven people along the
Raging San Diego River as the rains
flooded roadways and toppled trees in
the middle of night I heard a big crash
pretty crazy lucky no one got hurt it's
kind of hard to put into words Marjorie
Cruz worries another mudslide could
leave her without a home to return to we
just are at the mercy of this mud and
hoping and praying and keeping our
fingers crossed that it doesn't take the
rest of my house out
experts tell us the extreme drought here
in California has actually made the
state more susceptible to mudslides
after all of the rain here here in
Ventura County you drive by giant piles
of debris in some cases 40 feet high one
Community here saw its only Road blocked
by a Mudslide the sheriff's department
had to fly people out via helicopter and
the county says it could be months
before that road is usable again Tony
people cut off people digging out Chris
thank you very much